[Music]
some republicans are saying that due to
his current scandals president obama
should be impeached
that's what we're saying yeah
yeah in response obama laughed and said
two words fellas president biden
vermont has passed a new bill vermont
passed a new bill making it okay to
possess small amounts of marijuana
yeah the the bill was co-sponsored by
representatives ben and jerry
yeah
a little help
i think state senator dorito helped a
little bit
i like him
they all were working together hard
to keep this country great
today new jersey governor chris christie
spent the whole day with prince harry
yeah
christy gave prince harry the royal
treatment taking him to a white castle
and a burger king
[Applause]
[Music]
kim kardashian in the news again kim
kardashian and kanye west are having
serious disputes about how much privacy
they want from the media
yeah apparently the media wants to give
them some privacy and kim and kanye
don't want any
[Applause]
you don't know they are you paying
attention to what's uh the new tv season
what's coming up because they're making
all the announcements right now well
good i'll take your silence as a no
here's where i come in and tell you
what's going on
yeah they're announcing all the new
shows the upcoming tv season will have
fewer gay characters
yeah
well folks not if andy and i can help
[Applause]
that's
it
[Music]
let's do this yeah
let's go shopping for throw pillows
right now
that's not what i had in mind but all
right
you have you have your ideas i have mine
i thought we'd start slow it's true oh
it starts with throw pillows and then it
charges moves
each other with them that's right
it is true though the upcoming tv season
will have fewer gay characters yeah
folks this is what happens when you
cancel smash the new normal and csi west
hollywood
some of you may live there and i
if you do i apologize
this is interesting a chance to have
check this out a chance to have coffee
with apple ceo tim cook
is going for over six hundred thousand
dollars on an online auction
yeah yeah cook promised that meeting me
is like buying an apple product way
overpriced but you won't get a virus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes it works
it lines up nicely yes
continue you red-haired freak
about your business with your capering
and your dancing
i actually hadn't done that yet tonight
but
that felt good check this out
gang in kentucky
a man snuck into a grocery store
overnight and consumed 57 cans of
whipped cream a birthday cake beer and
cigarettes
yeah kentucky officials are telling
everybody to be on the lookout for a
health food freak
kentucky
ah thank you one guy
that was fantastic one guy
everybody's like uh one guy yeah
[Music]
i believe in coding
thanks man
i'll do the same for you one day
fox is trying to boost ratings by
bringing back the show 24.
yeah
yeah in it jack bauer has just 24 hours
to try to get people to watch american
idol again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my impression of the show 24.